this is maximum occupancy what's that
capacity maximum capacity
sounds like an 80s action film
jean-claude van damme in maximum
capacity well that was about just a
little Butler sounds like an 86 abu Boop
yeah that was definitely a mr. Bell over
here that's freezing lights or I would
say yeah I think I thought it was like
they do mr. Belvedere yeah just a Gaga
nothing I'm gonna do okay um but then
they're having it be a little kid the
super-rich family I mean that's
different strokes and Webster but
underneath all that this was really a
dark tale about cleaning cleaning out
the past um you know much like the much
like the one where Steven akane fuse I I
really like this one so I feel like
there's a lot of sort of various ways
you can take it um but it could be
something like really dark and heavy or
it can be something that is actually
very simple that can lead to something
really really emotional um the past can
just but you learn from it
I grab the key does yes from it oh yeah
run from it or learn from it what you
could do I'm gonna run back to my past
and then nobody's gonna support me I'm
gonna figure out my path was totally
false so this lesson is entirely
pointless well of course it is it is
because you're a Matthew Butterick
everybody likes you Hey Kassadin hi any
don't know why you day yeah we're guess
I should I care yeah um so this is an
episode where amethyst and Stevens dad
used to be friends used to be pals
watching this show there's pretty
obviously dumb show but they really
liked it and they bond over it sees my
but um and uh yeah so they start
watching it again they're supposed to
clean out the storage areas totally
trash amethyst not surprisingly it's not
very good at she wants to keep
everything um and we find out there's
kind of this big jealousy going on where
when Rose came into the picture uh he
spent more time with her and she felt
like that friendship was threatened so
they say
I'd say I called that one in my head
when Pearl was like and then they just
stopped and I was like mm-hmm rose well
as soon as she was looking as he was
looking at the picture and they had that
close-up of amethyst I'm like okay well
something like Apple watch it was like
yeah and I didn't know I was saying
myself they're not gonna go like that
that route I mean it kind of sounds like
they couldn't anyway from what the gem
understanding is or whatever cuz they
like I guess that's how they reproduce
or whatever but but yeah there's
definitely that idea of like there was
this tight friendship and then you know
wait if they can't reproduce where did
Steven come from no but Ramona she
became like she kind of is Steven she's
like how even I have what I'm losing
track about it stuff oh don't I don't
fully understand it but I guess
especially the way the episodes are
delivered piecemeal kind of like this
you forget certain facts yeah um but
someone will correct it for us well but
one of the nice things is that again I
think that's one of the reasons pearl
really obsesses over Steven you know
whatever connected her and Rose had I
mean she watches him sleep it's uh cuz
you he is at least half rose
uh and I really like in this one we
looking at the picture and like you'll
sort of show the reflection you'll see
like Steven in sort of her spot and
stuff like that like I like little
touches like that um but yeah I mean
this is something where and she kind of
tortures him a bit in that genuinely
uncomfortable moment kind of tortures I
was I could not think of a cruel thing
you might do I was legitimately
comfortable the good was his son second
pose as his dead wife yeah like I was
like why I was like the only thing I got
to get oh is worse would be full metal
alchemist with Hughes and last thing he
saw but I think and like I said and
they're very clever to hold odd they
don't show it I mean he's not looking
air for one and then when Steven comes
in and says stop and Steven sees her as
that I think that's a point where even
amethyst knows oh don't like that I've
really fucked up and this is becoming
what I've been doing bitch yeah
like it's like not only cruel it's like
sick and but there is something when you
have something you know that you've held
on to for so long and you haven't
addressed it I mean you can do sick
twisted stuff whether you realize or not
and yeah I think it's I don't know I I'm
sure you've come across this too I think
everybody's come across like friendships
where people used to be really really
tight but either life happens time
happens other people happen and stuff
and you kind crime happens crimes of
course um I made some wonderful jail
buddies okay um but something happens
where you can see absolutely but
something happens where you separate um
and it's like you're still friends
you're still in talk but like just stuff
that happens and changes and you kind of
miss that connection you had and
sometimes yeah when sometimes you
realize oh there was a reason why we
weren't talking and but it's tough it's
one of those things where it's like you
know you can't remember man what a good
friendship you had you know and how how
tight you used to be and use be able to
share so much but then like just
something and may not even just one
thing just a lot of things happen and
it's not something like there's a
falling out or you hate each other it's
just life gets in the way and you're
just not as close anymore um but but
then maybe something did happen like
more grounded than even were thinking I
mean II there was like a big blowup or
something but the way they sort of
talked and got along I mean it it kind
of felt like they were okay but even
when Steven brought her to help clean
she was like he was like oh and with
this well okay I guess this is all right
so there there was definitely a little
bit as unity presented itself yeah I
mean that they still seemed to be I mean
especially him he seemed to be like well
okay I mean we'll we'll go with this I'm
not gonna bring anything up I'm not
gonna say anything I know it was mostly
on her cuz she's the one who was trying
to stop him when he's like um I should
probably spend time with my son no but I
remember at the beginning she I think
she almost sees us I didn't do anything
wrong I'm fine well what are you talking
about it she was I got fine with hanging
out come on this'll be fun whatever uh
but he could always see the problem it's
it's like she didn't see the problem at
all
at first um and then when he wanted to
leave that's when I became a problem for
her um so yeah I think it's one of those
things where you know it's it's tough
money but its life and there are people
that just cannot let go certain things
or can't let them be and they want to do
anything to get it back um and there's
our people it's just like you know what
it sucks but you got it just it's it's
the way it is and what you traded for is
usually stuff that's essential and you
need usually um so yeah boy I prattle on
a lot there sorry you know oh no nothing
else that we already said it all I'm
sorry yeah I got a hug that's fine
that's fine please do a question you
know I'm done like you said I said it
all
and still I neither I liked that scene
at the end we're staring at the picture
and then it's it's rose and Stevens dad
and then bends it slightly and see the
reflection of Steven and his dad and the
same like kind of positions and I bet
that was a touching visual yeah I
actually brought that up too oh did you
yeah Wow I must have sewn down a lot of
people do when I talk um oh I will say
this I don't think it was intentional
but when amethyst says oh don't worry
I've gone through your junk you know I
okay okay here's my thought it probably
was intentional but not like a you know
hey we snuck the same kind of thing it's
just like hey looks just a cute little
dirty joke whatever but if it's I don't
it's just saying if it's not smart that
I kind of say it kinda minds me of
Batman and Robin where she's like I'll
help you grab your rocks it's like hey
hey like if it got a do they'd at least
be smart about it um but a job but again
I was almost wondering like are they
hinting it that no you know cause like I
said I you could take this as like I
guess in a fair thing but I really don't
read that into it especially for a kid
show I always like making innocent
things dirtier so I will totally think
but especially if they made that joke I
would think they're not leaning towards
that because again as really good
storytellers it doesn't feel like they
wouldn't make that joke for it um yeah
we're like a couple of gems in a rock
tumbler baby belgica pouch come on um so
yeah I guess the only other thing coming
to mind is that you know we were Navy
Brad so we moved around a lot so the
idea of like sort of this really tight
friendship that he has sort of drifting
apart was like nothing new I even argue
like we kind of added throughout most of
our lives so it's one of those things
where it's hard to say like wow I like
this really hit me in the fields like
big-time or anything cuz it's like I
aside from family I can
to give anyone that's like wow I've
known this person all my life like this
friend you know and a BFF uh you know
kids aside we just always more whatever
I hear people is like I have been best
friends with this person since we were
the age of 3m Wow
oh my god yeah I know forever and not
not all that that's bad and I would want
to move on I gotta move again I'm like
no frame of reference I'm like where we
cannot used to it like I what's the big
deal yeah there's pros and cons to both
I mean I get it if you've lived in the
same place for 20 years I'm like wow
that's gotta suck but yeah no real frame
of reference there's definitely pros and
cons to both I say the definite Pro for
us is that it's like you know it's
whenever something has to change we're
not that bad about it way to change
occasions or a house or people or
something like that it's not a big a
huge deal I mean sometimes it's the
Gypsy life baby yeah kind of um but the
downside is it's like yeah we've never
had someone like you said from age three
that it's like oh we can trust
everything with this person just based
on how long I've known the person again
outside of family uh but some of that is
not family um so you know there's pros
and cons to it but yeah it's something
where it's like I still get it I still
understand what they're talking about
here and I've seen sort of the con we've
never learned how to truly love this is
the pro we've never learned how to truly
well that was sad and as I said the two
married guys don't feel don't feel don't
feel don't even layer of about um but
yes just for me so yeah a really good
episode like I said I think you can sort
of take it a lot of ways I think
everybody whether or not you brought up
with someone that you've known since
childhood or or you moved around I think
everybody can kind of relate to this
with something in their life and again
they made it just vague enough just
singing around watching a show it's like
it can be anything that you know the two
people do that they bond over uh and
anything that can get in the way as well
so yeah I thought this did really well
and I thought it was just the right
amount
like specific but also open enough that
you can connect yourself to it as well
ditto
so uh yeah that's about it is the
national marble madness I just gotta
know what Marble Madness is here the
next one or the one after I just I
better see some fucking marble cascading
down some mazes or upward like the back
warm up ah the silly the silly level
everything you know is wrong it's tough
to roll ball baby it you had to roll
square like that would be technically
Brian would just sit there if you didn't
woman had to bounce the marble yeah and
you would lose every single tank is it's
a square and you can't move it there's
just like this is gonna go over like
most of our audiences Adam fuck is
flavor madness it is the most fun
fucking shortest game but it's so
enjoyable um if it probably sucks now
I'll play it I'm like this shit um this
pretend is 1988 all over again
yeah let's go watch no Butler and play
I'm of immense pleasure Marble Madness
ever shit little marble madness Rolen
bobbles come on knock him out though I
was gonna say because there's nothing
you could do with that then they did
have the Geico caveman shows yeah and
Donkey Kong jr. was a show the Rubik's
Cube was a show No why not Marble
Madness dammit and Cheers
that piece of shit half flock don't
watch cheers it's crap I don't any of
our audience watches anybody it's like
I'm thinking like we're gonna get all
this hey it it's just like nod up
probably nobody in our audience even
watches it actually I didn't mind cheers
that much I always have Frasier was a
little better but Seinfeld though half
half per my Butler for sly in the show
these pretzels are making me thirsty
okay goodbye